Clark County schools and a principal are
now the target of a federal lawsuit now
a claims administrators did not properly
investigate a bullying incident despite
being required to under law the alleged
incident happening at gerheim elementary
school just last week we reported how
the principal at that very same school
was accused by police of attempting to
cover up misconduct during a separate
child abuse investigation Joshua peguero
joining us now live in our Newsroom to
explain Joshua in this Federal lawsuit
you see here Michelle Cox a former
teacher at gerheim elementary says she
followed protocols to report The
Bullying of her own child but when
nothing was done she reported to the
state and for that she claims she was
retaliated against
in Cox's lawsuit she says her child was
subjected to bullying at gerheim during
the 2018-19 school year to the point
where another student told her child
quote when I am older I'm going to
murder somebody somebody like you the
administration and in our view had
dropped the ball and allowed the student
to continue to be harassed and bullied
Jason Bacchus Cox's lawyer in this
Federal lawsuit Ryan Lewis a principal
at gerheim at the time is accused of not
only failing to investigate the bullying
but also of suppressing reports
pertaining to any bullying incidents she
was retaliated against and accused of
wrongdoing before essentially for
raising her voice or questioning the
principal Cox says when gerheim
administrators failed to investigate the
bullying she reported it to the state
hotline safe voice coins to the lawsuit
that became the first official report on
filed since the school never filed one
although it's CCSD policy it goes on to
say administrators looked into the the
matter and determine Cox's allegation
was up substantiated but when an
associate superintendent took over the
case she disagreed she accused guerheim
administrators of not doing inadequate
investigation and not following protocol
additionally neither the students nor
the parents involved were interviewed by
administrators which is a requirement
the circulators accused gerheim's
principle of creating a climate that
allows bullying they had not conducted
the investigation that they said that
they had conducted and and she
recommended that certain action to take
place at that school and it's our
understanding
that no action took place
now Michelle Cox is no longer employing
the school according to the lawsuit she
was asked not to return from leave Ryan
Lewis the principal is no longer at the
school either CCSD confirmed me he's
been assigned to other duties reporting
live in The Newsroom Joshua peguero
eight news now